Ezard rants the segment where I take a
less structured a humorous approach to
look at any topic that crosses my mind
relating to the subject of anime and
manga it contains my raw biased opinion
and it's for the purpose of creating
debate and/or discussion so shouldn't be
taken too seriously got that great I
shut up and listen as an avid anime
watcher who's been watching it for many
years now there are some parts of the
anime community that I might find kind
of annoying in which you're fans of the
big three or as they like to be called
Tod's will blindly declare that they're
animes the best anime ever while
senselessly flaming anyone who disagrees
with them and yaoi fan go scare the hell
out of me and how they can think any
mail contacts implies a night of
ravaging sex but if there's one thing
that's always guaranteed to get my
piston to a boil its dub haters it's no
secret that one of the most Heatley
debated topic in every anime community
is sobbed and mode versus dubbed anime
which will inevitably end with a mutual
agreement there's or down to personal
preference well within this as always a
small fraction of people who no matter
what you say no matter how you argue or
no matter how good a dub is will
endlessly bash on the existence of dubs
as if the Japanese language is some sort
of sacred holy gift from God or
condemning the English language like
it's a hell spawn of Satan despite the
fact that is the language they [ __ ]
speak as long as there has been
animating the West there have also been
dubbed ators but while nowadays dub
haters consist mostly of weeaboos
elitists and newbies who think the
hardcore for listening to Japanese you
can already fold up haters for existing
way back when back when anime was just
starting out here in the 80s and 90s it
was a new industry where no one really
knew what they were doing so it would be
obvious that the quality of English
voice actors in comparison to the
Japanese ones will be very large
considering they had been doing this for
decades while dubbing companies in the
US were just starting out but then dubs
are commonly associated with hilariously
bad voice-acting incorrectly pronounce
names and voiceovers so boring and
monitoring that the government Capote
experiment with their voice and Modern
Warfare since I imagine playing some of
these monologues to the enemies would be
the real-life equivalent of summoning
Jigglypuff and telling it to be sing
attack dubs back then sucked yes there
was some that were okay but any anime
what she could tell you that 99% of the
shows just can match up in English the
Japanese language were just better
suited for anime and always would be
there would never be any show that would
actually be better with them English
soundtracks cause cause anime came from
Japan then something happens a certain
show came along that would forever
change everyone's perspective of dubs
[Music]
in September 2001 Cowboy Bebop aired for
the first time on a new programming
block called adult swim and exploded
onto American screens would help fuel
the beam of anime in the early 2000s
with Steve blooms iSchool portrayal
spike Spiegel Wendy Lee's fiery
depiction of play Valentine the fatherly
voice of Bo Billingsley as jet black and
Melissa fan as ever so hyperactive
radical Ed's it showed audiences that
Doug could not only match their Japanese
counterparts but damn right exceed it it
was so good in fact that to this day
Cowboy Bebop is still de de facto
standard that all modern dubs tried to
emulate and the one anime that everyone
seems to admit is better in English from
then on the show's just kept coming
flagship series like Trigon
yuu-yuu hakusho Big O Gundam Wing freely
Cooley and full metal alchemist appeared
on the small screens which starts the
first wave of thrill anime gross in the
West I would always be the dubs that
even now no one really complains about
it's been a decade since then and what's
changed or obviously the quality of
dubbing has increased immensely anime
has become a much larger business
meaning dubbing companies give get
better equipment and studios and a
handful of voice actors who started off
as amateurs I've been able to get
experience under their belts and improve
want to see what I mean just look at the
difference in quality between the
original overdubs and the more recent
rebuild movies although yes in both
versions shinji still screams like a
[ __ ] Thank You spike Spencer it's been
a long time since I've seen a badly
dubbed anime yes that's the mini that
inferior to the original soundtrack but
nothing that could be coined as
unlistenable and they're still
increasing numbers of dubs which are
just as good if not better than the
subbed version but unfortunately no
matter how great a dub is that always
seems to be haters the spider fighters
they're just as good as these all the
shows that never get any hate don't
believe me go in any dub trailer of any
news show on YouTube and there will
always be comments along the line of ah
my ears bleeding or dubbing my anime of
English voices star clear blur
ok that's French for shut up until this
name my video still gets dislikes and
comments just cuz of the fact that I
used dubbed clips so why does this still
happen they have always been subhuman
dub purist depending on personal
preferences which is totally reasonable
but the only ever seems to be hatred
towards dubs which i think is totally
uncalled for what is it about some anime
fans that go out of their way to condemn
these English voices and why do they
take it so personally when the show
they've been following gets licensed and
dubbed well here's my theory on the
whole thing one thing I think is a big
fact is that with the exponential growth
of the Internet
instantly available fansubs anime a lot
of these people see subs anime first
before dubbing companies can even
licence the show unlike in the old times
and most of the exposure came from the
English versions on television nowadays
they can just see their Japanese
versions on the net way before the doll
even comes out meaning they have an
abundance of time to get personally
attached to the voices they heard first
so when a dub does come out no matter
how good it is or how well acted it is
if the voices just sounds slightly
different from their Japanese
counterparts which 90% of the time they
are they'll start to rage fit this was
their show their characters and their
voices what the hell were these
Americans doing bastardizing the voices
they got so attached to at least I think
that's what's going on in their heads to
this I would say to them if they just
kept an open mind and actually gave time
to get accustomed to the new voices
instead of throwing a hissy fit after
watching a one-minute trailer they might
not actually hate it so much because I
think Johnny Yong Bosch put it the best
these guys are here as voice actors not
voice imitators they are there to give
their own perspective on the character
which sometimes makes it better and
sometimes makes it worse but you can't
really judge that after listening to it
for about 20 [ __ ] seconds secondly I
don't know where this notion came from
but some fans seem to have the idea in
their head that's taken to the Japanese
version just somehow makes them some
kind of superior fan who appreciates the
anime more fortunately in this original
form to which I would say get that
[ __ ] head out your ass there's no
tangible hierarchy for anime fandom and
there never will be
just because someone liked a dub version
of a show doesn't mean they appreciate
it at any less it just means they liked
a different version of the same thing
you liked and it certainly doesn't
[ __ ] mean you're better to them
because you enjoyed it in the original
Japanese version in fact you may not
know this but many Japanese directors
provide some input to dubs and if they
don't like it they can have something
changed so while this may not always
work out for the better you can't really
talk about appreciation if the original
creators approve a bit these are the two
main reasons I think dub haters exists I
know there are other common augments
given by dub hector's such as which ones
better
acted localization and translation
problems but these generally differ from
anime to animate and there are so many
little things to talk about that's I can
make another entire rant video comparing
the aesthetics of subs versus dubs I
will say though that I do find it a bit
stupid that most dub haters who have fun
about translation problems don't speak a
lick of Japanese I rely on amateur
fansubs rather than the official
professional translations to fuel their
arguments honestly I think the existence
of dub haters these days have less to do
with the quality of dubs and what
fans thinking some kind of status symbol
we're sticking to the original
soundtrack makes you somehow more of a
fan or people getting too attached to
the voices they heard it first so this
is a message shored up haters out there
not all English dubs are bad if you just
get off your high horse and give them a
chance instead of putting your entire
judgement on a 30-second youtube clip
you will see that there are plenty of
dubs are just as good as the subs
versions anyone with two working years
to tell you that dubs aren't as bad as
you make it out to be some animes are
better suited in Japanese and some
animes are better suited in English but
if it's just your personal preference to
be reading subtitles that's fine by me
so I'm asking you guys now what do you
think of dubbed anime and dub haters
leave a comment or video response for
your chance to get featured in my next
ranks anyway that's it for me now though
so with your responses to my last ranked
video has anime been lacking recently so
here I am making my first video response
to witches gears question has anime been
lacking recently now let me get this out
the way right now this point happen to
be extremely greatly voiced therefore my
regular viewers who are watching this
and wondering why I'm talking so fast
I'm mainly making a view of the same
[Music]
[Applause]